[Music]
what's up
it's tuesday yeah we're here i think
yeah it's tuesday
do we all have the same shirt on yeah
show them the shirt that show them a
shirt 13 13 13. yeah
that's fine oh my god
i realized it was just like a gang yeah
show the shirt that's it so
shirts yeah i just got a shirt sophie
got me this shirt it's a belated
birthday gift and here it is it just
arrived today
and look at this you guys the kittens of
mercy
yeah feed me first as always
yeah in case you guys don't know that's
actually a ripoff of an album cover by
sisters of mercy and it's called first
and last in all ways it looks just like
that
except it doesn't have that [ __ ]
little kitty head on the [ __ ] star
i don't think it has a star there at all
actually i think i think the stars
behind the cat
look yeah but um on the album cover it
doesn't have that at all it's just those
two red things
but that's the sisters of mercy logo i
haven't looked at that yeah
that's pretty cool feed me first as
always
that's cool that's it yeah yeah pokey
gets it yeah so i'm so glad it came here
just in time
i still can't believe we all have the
same t-shirt on yeah yeah we should we
should have coordinated well i was like
talking to you before the
thing started and i didn't know i didn't
even notice you see i make these things
so i got a bunch of different shirts and
to me they're just like
uniform work shirts i put them on every
day you know yeah i just
put on whatever i got like five or six
different ones and as i make new designs
i always
rip like four for myself because why not
well yeah because we gotta order the
blanks shirts and everything
so yeah somebody said percival release
personally i'd be shocked if they didn't
already have something
like that that's kind of what yeah cause
like you were
mentioning the meow house one yeah like
with the house they came from gotha cat
yeah that's a really cool
website i'm in like their facebook
community and everything too it's all
like
just got cats a lot of black cats and
stuff so i'm all into that but
yeah check out gotha cat i think it's
dot net and they have like all these
shirts and
it's like all over buffs of old goth
fans and stuff all right
that's hilarious oh also while i'm doing
shout outs i also want to say thank you
to
justin for increasing his patreon
support and also we have a new patron
logan oh cool i didn't know about them
yeah it was just uh it was just today i
think this might be the same logan that
like sends
uh me paypal donations okay every now
and then so thank you very much
logan yeah thank you welcome board
justin that's super awesome
yeah and uh once a quarter we'll send
out a shirt i send out a shirt to
everybody yeah
well we try to do it once a quarter
sometimes it gets delayed sometimes it's
just like two or three times a year but
we try to do it every
every time yeah when the pandemic first
hit i think we missed one
or it got delayed a couple months yeah
but
a lot some people depending on how long
they've been with us you know i've set
two
yeah instead of one for them depending
on where they are
but that's overseas too that reminds me
too i got somebody somebody commented on
the on our birth on my birthday show
like that we did saturday
yeah that they wanted a shirt and they
sent twenty dollars and it was judd
moused i
never got one and then they never got
back to me with like their size or their
address or which design they wanted so
if you're still out there if you're
listening
like let me know and i'll send you a
shirt right you can't send it unless we
don't know
don't we don't have your information
right exactly well like is where am i
going to set it to
yeah i can't just put it in the mail
i'll just wander around forever long
crews out there mowing so you guys are
going to yeah so if you guys hear
anything wow
that's what that is it's just like the
[ __ ] log because they always they're
like
hey they're recording and our neighbor
is like doing
i don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
over there they don't even have that
much lawn
somebody says hey there alex sophie and
jenny i'm not alex i don't know if i can
talk about it
he's saying hello to alex in the
comments but not you
oh you're not saying hello to me
well we're a lot cuter than you so he's
in there
with alex though is alex a girl i am not
probably probably i don't i don't know i
don't know
i never thought about it yeah all right
so uh
we actually ended up watching another
brand new movie last night although i
think the copyright's in 2018 but
everywhere it's like just got released
this year and this was a thriller called
alone now when i looked this up this is
actually playing in some theaters as
well
like not our altamonte springs one but i
think it's playing at fashion square
mall theater
so it is playing at some theaters but
it's also playing at vod at the same
time so i guess they dropped it around
the same time
because this like just came out so this
is basically
a survival thriller
i would call it yeah i guess um and i
found out later too that this is a
remake
like an american remake of a swedish
movie
called and i know i'm pronouncing this
wrong called first bunden
whatever it means gone okay um so yeah
that was made back in 2011 and i guess
this is like and the screenwriter was
the same
like so the swedish guys because we were
confused because
on we rented it from the xbox and it was
in the foreign category
and we're watching it going i'm like
this is in english i'm like
it's in english everyone's it's like is
it canada yeah
i thought it might have been canada it's
not it's oregon it was shot in oregon
so where'd that foreign thing come in
because i guess the screenwriter was
is swedish and it's based on his movie
like a swedish movie so it's like a
remake all right now this one
is actually a good movie i think oh we
all liked this yeah i liked it i liked
it a lot it got
it's getting four out of five stars on
xbox it's a very traditional linear
[ __ ] survival horror story kind of
like
uh it kind of reminded me of a mixture
of a couple movies
it started off it kind of reminded me of
duel remember when the [ __ ]
truck the truck driver is trying to kill
the dude in the car it kind of reminds
me of that
uh and then it ends up and this woman's
being stalked by this damn
stalker at first i thought there was
going to be some kind of a
trick to it i go how much i bet this is
the good guy he's not the bad guy no it
turns out he's bad
he's stalking her and trying to abduct
her and then it ends up
he ends up capturing her capturing her
and then she survives
then she escapes and uh runs out into
the woods and he hunts her down so then
then it ends up starting to be kind of
like predator
and she i said men's like predator the
sexual presence
she goes like the sexual predator yeah
it's like the sexual presence
the sexual predator the sexual predator
should be the name of the [ __ ] people
she's running through the jungle it
looks like the jungle yeah it's like
kind of like she's in a forest and
[ __ ]
anyway very linear story
very [ __ ] driving pretty uh
pretty exciting um so
but yeah no real surprises in terms of
like you know there's no real
you know uh what do you call them
there's no spin it's not real twistier
it's very simple it's very
straightforward like i said it's not the
most original premise obviously but
but it works yeah i thought like the
suspense of it was really well done
um you know the main character who's her
character name is
jessica she's played by jules wilcox i
think she's on bloodline which i think
is a series on netflix that i've heard a
little bit about
but so she's basically at the beginning
she's
moving away you don't find out why until
later she's had like a family tragedy
and i guess she's moving out or she's
gonna go stay with her parents or
something like that and it's like a
four-day drive right she says so she has
all her stuff in a u-haul
yeah and uh then she starts getting
followed by this creepo
who looks like [ __ ] uh william h
macy's character from boogie nights like
with the big [ __ ] porn stash and
stuff
yeah and like the big stupid glasses
yeah the guy does a great job at this
character though he does good job he's
super creepy i don't know if he has
dentures on or if his teeth are just
really that creepy naturally
or if he just decided he was really
noticing he's like i'm gonna pull my lip
back a little bit and bit and make it
like he's like the quintessential
basically basically sexual predator
though yeah i mean he looks like what
you'd imagine
if he had been driving like a windowless
white van he would have just like ticked
all the boxes
the the whole kind of movie kind of
reminded me in total it kind of reminded
me of
of a of a crustal movie called breakdown
remember breakdown yeah it was a bit
like that
yeah if you like breakdown you like this
one and you're not the only person that
compared it to duel too because like
it's kind of divided into like five
chapters like of different places
that happen because this guy's like kind
of stalking her because she's like you
know on a long road trip like on her own
yeah and um so at the beginning it's
very much
vehicular like yeah it's like following
and still one thing that i really like
about this
liked about this movie because i i like
thrillers and i watch a lot of them
but i you know in horror movies too but
it's like obviously
a lot of horror movies and thrillers
have people doing really stupid [ __ ] and
everyone's just sitting there going what
are you doing
why would you do that you know what and
the thing that i liked about this movie
is
that she didn't really do that she
didn't really do anything overtly dumb
i mean she did pretty much a couple of
things that i was like oh
you should you should speed that along
and she went too long here and there but
yeah but it was like understandable it's
like she didn't do because you know
there was one scene in the beginning
where the guy's like obviously trying to
block the road and he's like acting he's
doing like some ted bundy shoes like oh
help me out
you know all this other stuff and i feel
like in a lot of thrillers the lady be
like okay i'll give you a ride
this lady's like nope bye
you know what i mean so it's like you
know when she calls the cops when you
know most people would call the cops
just she doesn't do anything like
overtly stupid yes she takes a little
too long to do some things probably
because she's scared
but i didn't really get a sense that she
was just doing anything completely
idiotic
which was a nice it was refreshing in
the victim's reading she gets like an a
yeah yeah i mean you know she's pretty
good
but yeah i mean like i said it's a very
it's a very simple story
um you know basically just woman gets
stalked kidnapped by
creeper and then has to like struggle to
survive
and that's pretty much the entire move
but it was it's so well done it's like
really suspenseful
um you know that's really all we can say
about it and it seems to be getting like
really good reviews it seems like
i can say a little bit more about it
okay the movie doesn't make
mistakes a lot of the common mistakes
you'd have today
uh it does not try to get into too much
explaining [ __ ]
or telling you [ __ ] it has very little
dialogue really
it's just showing you what happened not
a lot of backstory you know
a little bit but for her like none
foreign anyway
it's better to leave certain things
[ __ ] on on you know what i mean
unexplained i i liked it i liked it
because it wasn't dialogue heavy
and the thing about it too is that
pretty much and particularly women and
i'm sure men too but like pretty much
any woman that watches the movie can
identify with that character
because everybody's had something
similar like that happen like you think
you're being followed or some weird
creeper is like
you know looking at you funny or
something like that so i feel like you
don't need
a lot of character development or you
don't need a lot of like unnecessary
exposition
to kind of get into her shoes and get
into because everybody can relate to
that situation i think there are only
three characters that you see in the
movie
maybe yeah her him and one other and
hunter that's it and the hunter
yeah is that oh wow i never really
really who's played by he's played by
the guy that played like the douchey
um head of the asylum in silence of the
lamps
yeah that guy what's it what the [ __ ]
his name alex healed
as i want to say his last name is yeah
he was yeah he was in silence and lambs
because uh yeah he had a brief
thing in it too but yeah i don't think
you hear other people's voices like on
the phone
but i don't think you see anybody else
now that i'm thinking about it yeah so
it's three
characters yeah so this movie probably
cost nothing to make it
very low yeah but it had had suspense it
had action in it
there's action scenes and everything
different kinds of action scenes it's
good
real good yeah i liked that it kind of
like went it moved from location to
location you know what i mean because it
was kind of like an extended like
several day yeah deal you know yeah and
you know the the
uh the the lead character is female but
she's she's kind of the hero of the
whole thing you got to root for to try
to make it through this and she's not
really
it's not one of those kind of like
italian movie type damsels in distress
where she just sits there and lets the
zombie eaters
she's already in like a a stressed
emotional
so i think she's already kind of like
she's not ditzy or anything like that
she's just she's just trying to move
so yeah she does run she runs she fights
she figures [ __ ] out
she does like what a normal person would
do and she's not and it's not like
unbelievable in the sense that oh she's
super badass yeah she's not cutting back
flips or anything she's just a regular
she's just a regular person and i think
that really helps too like
you know she doesn't really want to risk
like you know messing with firearms and
stuff and she doesn't know how to do it
and like
you know what i mean so she does try to
like do things and get one over but
she's not like like you said she's not
doing cartwheels and like kicking people
and knocking them out right
yeah in like the second phase of it when
she's doing the uh the jungle survival
or the
floor forest survival [ __ ] it kind of
reminds me a cross between like the
predator and like uh something out of
the most dangerous game
yeah where you're he's hunting her like
she's an animal
it's pretty interesting pretty good
pretty good and i really like i mean the
end of it was like
pretty brutal like the way they did it
like i said it's not like real
overdone it's not or anything like that
it's a lot more realistic
realistic kind of yeah and i think when
it got to the end i was just like that
last kind of battle i was just like yeah
you know it's like i was getting all
into it yeah it's good
it's a good example of how you take uh
just kind of um
a small budget movie and still like
execute it real well had a real good
score
yeah well i like the score wasn't over
the top which i liked about it it wasn't
like
yeah it wasn't like a real life visit oh
this is a scary moment like
i mean it wasn't like that the the the
the the the
i guess you could say kind of like the
format the movie is told in is very much
the shining
like kubrick with the [ __ ] dates and
what's happening next remember
remember that there would be like a yeah
the opening sequence was very
very much like the shining i thought
like not real overtly but in a way that
was
dealt with they were kind of homogeneous
yeah and like when the day would
progress it would show you what date it
is boom
and didn't it say some like give it like
a title like it was in chapter
chapters like in five chapters like the
river and yeah that's right that's stuff
like that yeah the basement or whatever
that one
it felt [ __ ] very standard kubrick
very shiny
it's good real good yeah yeah it's also
cool because like you follow
her and you don't get like in some
movies like this they'll do these
cutaways to like the police's
point of view or something like that
yeah yeah where you're like kind of
seeing like oh they're hunting this dude
over like you
you hear her talking to people you said
she'll call 9-1-1 and stuff but
there is all you're following is her so
you don't really know what's going on
outside of that
and it never leaves that action yeah
it's like it's kind of one long
continuous
right just yeah just just that one third
person view on her that's it yeah
there's no cuts to like anybody else's
perspective or anything like that
or even the killer's perspective
perspective they don't really go into
his like she like sees him doing things
but they don't
explain why he is the way he is or when
they don't show
you know anything that's going on
outside of his life like i said they
don't even really
there aren't even any flashbacks in it
are there i think you just find
out a little bit with her with her
camera or her video yeah
she had a video that he was watching and
stuff but that's about it but that was
yeah they didn't do like any kind of
cheesy like
you know i had a nightmare about the
family tragedy that they found me and
i'm all messed up and everything so
that was i think that thought that was
good that they kept that it was very
like minimalist yeah and i thought that
that like really worked in its favor
like i said it's not a super original
premise obviously there have been a lot
of movies like this
but i just thought it was really really
well executed it just goes to show that
you don't need like a bunch of
extraneous kind of crap like to get
into a character and get into the movie
and like actually like be
riveted to you know until the end like
to find out what's going to happen you
don't even really need
a new or you don't even really need a
new story
yeah you know what i mean just do it
well yes yes i mean because there's no
such thing as a new story yeah they're
all been done
everything's been done pretty much as
sad as that is i mean i could be wrong
about that maybe somebody can think of
something completely original but i
would be very surprised we got five
lifetimes of [ __ ] good of of movies
out there
most of them [ __ ] yeah but there are
some good ones too
so you know what i mean you're never
going to be able to come with something
100 original
even if you come up with the original
idea certain scenes in the in that movie
you're going to be like yeah that's a
scene like a scene out of another movie
well because everybody's influenced by
stuff that they saw even if you don't
remember it
right because i've done some [ __ ] do you
know what i did a few years ago like i
drew
like something and this was a while back
but i drew like this picture or whatever
and i was like oh that came out really
nice and then like a year or two later i
was like flipping through this really
old book and there was a picture in
there that was almost exactly like that
one
right and it was like a book that i must
have seen when i was younger
and it must have just like made an
impression on me enough then and then so
i just thought it was like
so i think that kind of happens a lot um
yeah this was so this was directed by
john hiams
who i think he also did that series
black summer the zombie series didn't we
watch that or do we start watching it
it sounds kind of familiar i remember
that being pretty good too but yeah so
like i said this is on vod you can rent
it um i think it's also playing in some
theaters at least it was playing in a
couple theaters around orlando we got
ours off xbox one yeah we just got off
our uh i think it was 6.99 to rent it
yeah
so yeah it was like really good and like
i said it seems pretty highly rated and
i can see why because it's just very
simple it's just very creepy suspenseful
and
yeah nothing pissy off about it it's
just normal yeah it's just it's just
like a really riveting like
story where you're just like rooting for
this girl to like get away from the
psychopath you know i mean
so um all right so that'll do it for
today's we'll be back again tomorrow
probably do another
new or newish movie uh so we'll talk to
you guys again tomorrow thanks for
dropping by as always
and bye bye